podría considerarse un milagro navideño
algo de alegría festiva está surgiendo
en las ciudades de francia mientras se
alzan los árboles de navidad en las
calles y en los centros comerciales
[Música]
conocido por su mercado navideño
cancelado este año
estrasburgo le dio la bienvenida a su
icónico gran spin como todos los años es
precioso no puedo esperar para verlo
iluminado con las restricciones sólo se
permiten los artículos esenciales la
semana pasada el gobierno agregó los
árboles de navidad aunque todavía está
cerrada la floristería puede vender
árboles al aire libre
sería triste un árbol sin regalos sin
celebraciones sin diversión para los
niños
los árboles constituyen una gran parte
de los ingresos anuales de los floristas
pero al ser una gran parte de nuestro
negocio y la capacidad de vender estos
árboles cara a cara cambian las cosas
por un lado los productores de árboles
de navidad se pusieron en marcha la
mayoría proviene del parque natural los
fans y la navidad puede representar más
de una cuarta parte de sus ventas
anuales dibujado hoy cortaremos unos 700
750 árboles fac para la mayoría de los
productores la autorización a la venta
de árboles llegó justo a tiempo por
suerte lo supimos porque después del 20
de noviembre habría sido demasiado tarde
no hubiéramos tenido tiempo de cortar
los árboles ni entregarlos hay mucho
trabajo por delante el año pasado los
franceses compraron casi 6 millones de
árboles